- At this point in the show,
I always love to share something
that I'm lovin' on social media.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
So if you have a dog or have ever had one,
you know that you're
constantly trying to teach them
and train them
but you may not actually know
how much dogs can teach us.
So a New Jersey veterinarian
says that she learned a lot
from pups as she was battling cancer.
And now she's written a
self-help book about it
and it's called "Sit, Stay, Heal."
Great title.
We have her on the line right now.
Let's say hello to Dr. Renee,
watching on NBC4 New York.
(audience applauds)
- Hi, Dr. Renee.
So first of all, tell
us about your diagnosis
and how you're feeling today.
- Okay.
Thank you, Kelly, for having me on.
I was diagnosed with cancer in 2018,
and in fact, I am the poster child
for why we all need to go
get checked every single year
because I had no clinical signs.
Unfortunately, at my
gynecology yearly appointment,
my doctor noticed a
small mass in my uterus
which was uterine cancer.
Since that time, I've had surgery,
numerous months of chemotherapy
and radiation therapy.
But thankfully, right
now my doctors are using
the good C word or "cure."
I don't wanna jinx myself or
the universe but I'm doing well
and they don't need to see
me back for a whole year.
- That's incredible.
(audience applauds)
Congratulations on that.
And you say that your dog
and the dogs that you treat
helped you get through this.
How so?
- So I have been a
veterinarian for 30 years
and I've always learned from my patients
but especially when I had cancer.
For me, my treatment was hard,
but my dog looked at me with such love,
which gave me strength.
He didn't judge me.
I also knew-
During my treatment, I would worry
that perhaps the chemotherapy
nurse couldn't hit my vein.
But dogs don't do that.
They don't use their
energy to fret or to worry.
They only use it for positive things.
So I put all of that in my book,
truly life lessons from dogs,
helping us to all hopefully live happier.
- It's so important.
(audience applauds)
Yeah, you go through something
and share it with the world
and connect with other people
that might need that message.
So thank you so much Dr. Renee.
I'm liking your post right now, all right?
(audience applauds)
- Thank you.
(heart emoji pings)
- All right, everybody.
So we've reached the end of the show
and we have something special
for someone in the audience
courtesy of our season-long partner
Pilot pen, makers of FriXion,
the go-to erasable pin of
the Kelly Clarkson Show.
So there's a check for $1,000
under one of your chairs, taped.
So look.
(drumroll music)
(Kelly laughs)
Who's got it?
Who's going shopping?
Yay!
(audience applauds)
- Hey.
- Hello.
- What in the world?
- What's your-
What's your name?
- I'm Lily and I'm the
biggest fan of you, Kelly.
What the heck?
Oh my God, this is crazy.
- I love it.
How do you think you're
gonna spend that money?
- Concert tickets.
- Yeah.
(Lily laughs)
(audience applauds)
What a great answer.
- And I've never seen you in concert
so maybe if there's a show
sometime down the road.
- I don't know, maybe there
might be one coming on.
I dunno.
I can't say it so...
But you might be able to use it.
I'm gonna plan for that.
So anyway, can't let
the cat outta the bag.
Thank you so much and I
hope you enjoy the money.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you!
- Thank you to all our guests this hour.
Ike Barinholtz, Sarah
Ferguson, the Duchess of York,
and all members of Twice.
Y'all have a great day.
(audience applauds)